se empieza a sentir la presión mientras
los líderes mundiales se reúnen en nueva
york' el reto de esta asamblea general
de la onu es reparar la fragmentación
provocada por la invasión rusa de
ucrania entre por un lado occidente que
apoya a kiev y por otro rusia apoyada
por un puñado de estados y
cuidadosamente por chino en el medio
inia y decenas de otros países de áfrica
asia y suramérica que se muestran
cautelosos a la hora de tomar partido
preocupados por las consecuencias de la
guerra en la economía mundial el jefe de
la política exterior de la unión europea
subrayó que abordar la cuestión de
ucrania es inevitable
el pueblo ucraniano es haciendo
bombardeado con misiles y armas y el
resto del mundo se está viendo afectado
por el aumento de los precios de la
energía y los alimentos- hay muchos
otros problemas lo sabemos pero la
guerra en ucrania ha provocado
perturbaciones en todo el mundo
sin embargo muchas delegaciones ya
advierten que no quieren que ucrania
domine toda la asamblea los impactos
devastadores del cambio climático ya se
están sintiendo de forma
desproporcionada en los países del sur
global continúan las crisis en malí
afganistán y yemen y aumentan las
tensiones por el comportamiento de china
frente a taiwán la ministra de
exteriores francesa también advirtió que
las posibilidades de resucitar el
acuerdo nuclear con irán de 2015 se
están alejando y sagarpa no habrá una
oferta mejor en la mesa para irán les
corresponde tomar una decisión sencilla
y llegan quiere garantías de eeuu de que
no se retirará del acuerdo de nuevo algo
que washington dice que no puede
prometer por parte de las futuras
administraciones por lo visto las
divididas naciones unidas tienen mucho
trabajo por delante